kim kardashian west and pete davidson
gave fans a real thrill over the weekend
when they were spotted holding hands on
a roller coaster at not scary farm i
think halloween is a total excuse just
to stand out the 41 year old kkw beauty
founder and the 27 year old saturday
night live star hit the theme park with
kourtney kardashian her fiance travis
barker and a few of their friends for a
spooky night out
[Music]
the group went on several rides where
kim and pete paired off and shared a
cart by themselves on one of the park's
many roller coasters and if you look
closely you'll see kim clutching onto
pete's hand
it was calming so all that was on friday
and a source tells e.t that on saturday
pete was spotted having lunch with two
guy friends at the beverly hills hotel
quote he was texting on his phone and
looked very happy and giddy whenever he
looked down at his phone he seemed like
he was in a great mood
so should fans start thinking of a
couple name for kim and pete
maybe not according to a separate source
kim and pete quote have fun together
adding quote pete is a friend of
travis's so it's a good time when they
all get together
it's a different experience for sure
of course the two first made headlines a
few weeks back when kim hosted snl
uh i'm just a little concerned that
physically
i can't handle you
if we go all the way
he might like break me before their spin
on the roller coaster the two shared a
magic carpet ride on saturday night live
where they did a little more than
hand-holding
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
of course kim filed for divorce from
kanye west back in february after six
years of marriage now a source tells e.t
that the reality star just wants to be
peaceful with a grammy winner and have a
healthy and supportive co-parenting
relationship for the sake of their four
kids him and i have been best friends
for a really long time and while the
source adds that things can get
overwhelming quote kim and kanye have a
lot of love and respect for each other
[Music]
you